Sommerzeit ein Tag am Meer der
Timmendorfer Strand an der Ostsee am
Mittag schon proppenvoll 31 18 heute die
magische temperaturenkombination die den
Strand zum Sehnsuchtsort macht für jeden
der dringend nach Abkühlung sucht weil
es zu Hause viel zu heiß ist schöne
kühle Ostsee die Touristen lieben es
hier ist die Hitze erträglicher als bei
uns muss ich sagen also durch das Wasser
halt hier sehr schön nicht zu kalt ist
schon wichtig weil das Wasser ist jetzt
ziemlich kalt wir kommen aus dem
Ruhrgebiet und ähm bei 30 Grad ist es da
nicht auszuhalten
die Sommerzeit ist in Stuttgart oft
nicht so angenehm die Stadt liegt in
einem Talkessel unten viel Asphalt und
Beton Stuttgart heizt sich schnell auf
Anfang der Woche Temperaturen weit über
30 Grad kaum auszuhalten in der Stadt
ja ist schon unerträglich weil steht
halt hier in der Stadt durch die ganzen
hohen Gebäude und so geht kaum Luft zu
also sehr anstrengend auch wenn man
jetzt in der Stadt arbeiten geht finde
ich selbst mit Klimaanlage manchmal viel
zu warm
das ist so heiß ist
weil keine Ahnung es hat alles viel
anstrengender
Johannes Wagner leitet die Notaufnahme
im Klinikum Stuttgart bis zu zehn
Prozent mehr Patienten die meisten über
60 kommen hier an den heißen Tagen rein
Wagners Prognose es werden in Zukunft
immer mehr was wir jetzt in der gesamten
Bundesrepublik aber auch europaweit
feststellen dass einfach die Zahl der
Hitze tot nach oben geht und
gleichzeitig die Zahl der Kälte Toten
nach unten geht und dementsprechend
müssen wir uns natürlich alle
miteinander auf diesen
Klimawandel oder auf die veränderten
Temperaturverhältnisse vorbereiten über
30 Grad in München und Danny Müller ist
mit dem Rad unterwegs beruflich Denny
ist ambulante Krankenpfleger und
versorgt Patienten zu Hause gut
angeschwitzt kommt der an bei den
Fliegers hallo
grüß sie die Fliegers haben eine
Dachgeschosswohnung das macht alles noch
mal wärmer Herr Flieger ist 88 und
herzkrank das Wetter setzt ihm sehr zu
probieren Sie es mal ja nimmst ja
richtig die Hand aufmachen richtig
drüber fahren und trinken ist wichtig
äußere Abkühlung auch in diesen Tagen so
ein gekühlter Waschlappen bringt schon
was und der Pfleger hat noch mehr Tipps
die Handtücher zum Beispiel ja könnte
gekühlt werden ihre Decke zum Beispiel
Herr Tiger könnte man vielleicht bevor
sie ins Bett gehen noch mal richtig auf
dem Balkon raushängen Danny weiß genau
wie gefährlich so ein heißer Sommer für
alte Menschen sein kann also ist genauso
auch Herzinfarkt und Schlaganfall
fördern
gerade im Sommer oder der Körper einfach
mehr schwitzt an der Körper
Flüssigkeiten abdunstet
[Musik]
da ist halt die besondere Gefahr mit
dabei
Danny schwitzt natürlich auch aber
weiter geht's aufs Rad in die Hitze zu
den nächsten Designer Hilfe brauchen
Hitzewellen werden wohl immer länger mit
immer höheren Temperaturen die
Bundesregierung will nun ein
klimaanpassungsgesetz auf den Weg
bringen Kommunen sollen auch
städteplanerisch auf die Veränderungen
durch den Klimawandel reagieren wie man
es nicht machen sollte sieht man in
Mainz ein neues Stadtquartier ist gerade
fertig geworden mit Wohnungen und Läden
dazwischen ein Platz 4000 Quadratmeter
dunkler Asphalt über einer Tiefgarage
alles andere als optimal für heiße
Sommertage die neuen Bewohner sind sauer
der schwarze Asphalt
wurde und zu wenig Grün angelegt wurde
es ist eine sehr sehr große versiegelte
Fläche wer vielleicht auch noch mehr
gegangen aber ähm ja letztendlich muss
es eine Architekt natürlich oder ein
Stadtplaner dann auch entsprechend
mitdenken der müsste man noch mal
vielleicht die Kommunalpolitik fragen
warum
da nicht anders geplant wurde wir fragen
nach die Planung soll Jahre alt
eigentlich von gestern trotz allem hielt
man bis heute daran fest nicht gut
gelaufen das weiß man auch im Rathaus
Sachen momentan schon länger geplant
sind Tiefgaragen unter Plätzen gehört
meiner Meinung wirklich der
Vergangenheit an weil wir wissen dass
wir darauf z.B keine Bäume pflanzen
können immerhin der Belag soll demnächst
durch helleren ersetzt werden und doch
etwas Grün soll drumherum kommen meins
arbeitet noch an der hitzeschutzplanung
im bayerischen Straubing ist man schon
weiter Hitze gibt es hier auch aber es
gibt auch viele schattige Plätze
Trinkbrunnen für alle und sogar eine
sprühnebel-anlage mitten in der
Fußgängerzone alles recht neu und von
den Straubingern selbst gewünscht in
einer Umfrage der Stadt zu Maßnahmen
gegen die Hitze
im Ausland wie in Italien da gibt es ja
auch schon und genau und da ist halt
Deutschland noch bisher ein bisschen
hinterher das soll ja so kleine
wassersprenkelanlage für Kinder da sein
und Doc freimannschaft man konsumiert
immer verhindern dass man jetzt mittags
mehr raus muss oder ähnliches und ich
finde zu dass man da kennt das dort
einiges durch und versucht Albert Sonne
der versucht er ist Arzt und
Bürgermeister von Straubing für seine
Stadt hat er den hitzeschutzplan
ausgetüftelt einzigartig in Bayern und
auch deutschlandweit noch eine
Seltenheit was jetzt nicht steckt die
ballischen Bereich betrifft dass wir
umdenken müssen wir haben ja ganz viele
große Plätze bei uns in unserem Land die
einfach Hitze ansaugen und
in denen es einfach heiß ist und dann
müssen wir die baulich einfach dagegen
aber grün vor grau mehr Bäume und
Bepflanzung sollen das Straubinger Stadt
Klima erträglich halten Straubing
vielleicht heute schon auf dem Weg in
die Zukunft